thank you for the time as always it's a
pleasure to be here I get to talk about
three of my favorite things and that is
AI and blockchain and Python so let's
get started
some of you might know this plot it's
pretty famous these days I and it was
actually published in 2001 and what it
shows is that data is wildly powerful I
was doing a re search in the 90s
actually for National Defense Canada and
I was given a data set it had about
20,000 data points I think 20 30
dimensions and I spent my summer two
summers in a row actually playing with
this data set trying to have a little
bit better algorithm and so on I was
trying to improve the error rate from 35
percent to 30 percent right and it was
supposed to be deployed you know for for
these uses but you know if you're going
from 35 percent to 30 percent what does
that mean it means your model is still
terrible right so and you can do
whatever you want you can have the
world's greatest model but it just
doesn't have enough information to build
something interesting and this was
actually how a lot of a I worked for
many many years was you would have a
fixed data set you'd work with it you
would compete with others for publishing
and so on by improving you know error
rate by 0.1 percent here or sorry 1
percent here 5 percent there or maybe 20
percent learning and so on like 20
percent faster but most of it really
wasn't usable because the errors were
still 20 or 30 percent and what you
really need is errors of 5 percent or 1
percent or even less depending on the
application
so what michelin here is research out of
Microsoft Bank Len Brill where initially
most people had been working on when
they had two hundred thousand words to
work with and with those Tunick thousand
words there was all these different
algorithms that were competing and
standard algorithms right like canon and
perceptrons naivebayes this sort of
thing and they were all competing
basically of error rates from anywhere
from 17 percent to 25 percent right and
you know three or four probably 20
publications just out of that but what
these researchers did they said okay
instead of changing the algorithm let's
change the data let's have more data and
not just 2x more data but 10x a thousand
X 10,000 X and what happened was it
showed that as we all know now at the
standard thing the data was unreasonably
effective so when you actually went up
to
1 billion words then the error rates
actually got 5% and it didn't actually
really matter which algorithm you had
they all improved and in fact which
algorithm was better you know it changed
depending on the amount of data so the
answer the the summary of this is that
data is unreasonably effective and that
sort of a title from my 2005 paper by
Peter Norvig and so on out of Google and
that was also ten years ago this paper
from from Google and since that time
what has happened is the people who have
the data and the AI expertise are making
fortunes most notably Google who saw it
long ago and Amazon for recommendations
and more more data with the appropriate
compute power of course two leads to
more accuracy now that we have the
models with the capacity deep nets and
so on leads to higher click-through
rates more sales etc which leads to more
money so the race is on for more data
now let's frame this in the context of
the elements of computing I always love
to go back to first principles and the
elements of computing our storage
processing and communication we all know
this and within that you know in terms
of a stack going on in the world of AI
and machine learning this is kind of
standard stuff it's boring but I'm going
to relate this later on to
decentralization so for storage we've
got things like file systems HDFS you
know for holding these giant data leaks
of data s3 from major data blobs and so
on for databases we've got large-scale
distributed databases like MongoDB
Cassandra and another 50 like that right
for processing
you know we've got business logic from
CPUs or Elastic Compute cloud and so on
but then also going when we have really
massive compute needs that's when we're
using things like GPUs from Nvidia or
maybe the more recent Google tensor
processing units MapReduce and spark as
some of the software to help drive all
of this right and the shades of gray
this is actually where you have this is
really the the building blocks that the
AI really needs so there's you know less
of a push for a needing to run with ec2
because that's just going to be too
expensive and of course to connect it
all together we have things like tcp/ip
to connect the different networks and so
on but really it's it's all about
storing massive amounts of data on the
file systems in the databases which are
storage and then the processing
with high-performance computer so you
know we've made great progress you'll
see many many amazing talks today and
yesterday and tomorrow with PI data but
all is not well in the world of AI as
probably some of us know one thing is
data hoarding right if you're a startup
in AI where are you gonna get the data
from right and the big guys have tons of
the data lots of data and you can get
some as a start-up but you have to be
really sneaky or smart or spend a lot of
money also a week data history this is
classic
a for ISM from computer science garbage
in garbage out well the same is true
when you're training machine learning
models right if you have terrible data
coming in
maybe that's untrustworthy and so on
then you'll have terrible models and
data is expensive it's hard to price
this high friction on this so there's a
lot of challenges here right so recently
sort of the last half a year a year I've
been asking myself can decentralization
help this and so you know a bit of
history I did AI from the mid nineties
all the way up until about three years
ago four years ago full-time and then I
went basically full time into blockchain
and decentralization and I actually have
to admit I really missed a I write I
love AI continue to run the ML meetup
here with others and so it was probably
inevitable that I really try to merge
these worlds I was thinking about it
just because I thought it was you know a
cool thing to think about but what I've
come to realize is oh my goodness
there's really a lot of things that we
can do that mix AI and blockchain in a
really powerful way that can actually
help the world of AI and just to kind of
give a bit of a baseline here one of the
key things is to unlock blockchain
technology for AI one of the
prerequisites is scale just like we saw
from the unreasonable effectiveness of
data you really needed scale you needed
a lot of data to get there and this is
very different you know in the world of
AI and the nineties once again I
remember conversations with AI friends
they're like yeah we've connected the
dots we've showed that it's possible now
all we need to do is scale it up as if
that was like the last 5% of the problem
and you know what we've learned since is
it's not the last 5% it's the first 99.9
percent of the problem right in fact
that you know as we know the deep
learning models of today they're not
that different from the perceptrons of
the late 50s well then
linear ones from the early 60s to be
precise it's not that different right we
have better regularization and a few
other nice tricks but it's actually not
that different so the same thing here
though so we really to unlock
blockchains for AI data is job sorry
scale is job one and databases of course
go back a long time this sort of a
history of databases Oracle was the
first company to really successfully
commercialize relational databases
sequel style in the early 80s and they
became very successful and then when
websites took off then my sequel came
along and made it much easier for
startups to have their own database
rather than having to spend a hundred
thousand or a million on some Oracle
deployment since that time scale really
started to matter for more and more
companies so the large scale stuff that
Google and others were doing started to
filter down and meet be available to the
startups of the world through things
like MongoDB Cassandra and so on and
that's really the the trick there was
distributed databases right it was the
idea that you could spread the compute
load or storage load across more than
one physical resource right it was still
centralized there was still one entity
controlling all of it but it was
actually spread now there's a new type
of blue ocean each of these steps was
sort of blue ocean from the past right
going from relational databases to my
sequel it was D emphasizing some of the
things that cared before and adding new
things that mattered whether it's adding
open source nests with step two adding
scale with step three and what
blockchain technology does is it
actually adds new features new specs
that are interesting and in this case
it's really a couple its decentralized
that is no single entity owns or
controls it right and this has a lot of
value
it really helps for politics it helps
for sharing and pooling data and so on
as well see it also has this notion of
assets are these days people talk about
tokens right so you've got basically own
a token if you have the private key to
it and that can be transferred around on
this decentralized substrate and that's
very very powerful and that's things
that have unlocked this ICO madness of
today so in as a you can frame this in
the blue ocean sense to then basically
there is the idea of a blue ocean
database for block chains so just like
we had big data distributed databases
now we have decentralized databases or
blockchain databases and this is where
I'm spending my time big chain to be an
IPTV
and another way to think about this is
on the left here we see a picture of a
distributed database MongoDB or
Cassandra or whatever and there's a
whole bunch of clients on the top right
using it it could be 10,000 clients and
but in terms of control there's just one
admin right one dude or female in some
corner just running something so it's
centralized control and the difference
with blockchain databases is that you
have a whole bunch of kosis admin's you
could have five you could have five
hundred right and if a few of them start
acting maliciously that's okay
right and so that's really the core idea
and it actually unlocks a whole bunch of
other things so going back to the sort
of stack of the elements of computing
I've talked about the ones that were
important for AI here's actually what's
happening in the world of
decentralization and blockchain these
elements are all getting decentralized
one block at a time
so for storage rather than just things
like s3 and HDFS we now have ipfs the
interplanetary file system and file coin
for the equivalent of s3 storage we have
swarm we have storage with a J and so on
in terms of databases that's where big
Chain DB and IPTV come in IP DB is the
the planetary network version of big
chain DB software and we actually have
storage of tokens or call it e gold or e
cache and this is actually where things
like Bitcoin and Z cache fit in so
there's sort of new categories that have
emerged as well in processing business
logic the most famous out there is
aetherium so if you might have heard the
word smart contract that's really
basically code that runs on
decentralized processing substrate
specifically for business logic right so
it's not smart it's not really a
contract so it's decentralized
processing but it's a great label all
right it got gets people's attention
what's emerging also is decentralized
high performance compute right and there
are actually several emerging
technologies true--but gollum i exac
these are among the more famous but
what's also interesting what we've been
seeing is that virtual machines can
actually simply be handed around you can
actually treat VMs as assets right so
you can actually have a database that
remembers who's doing what and then just
have and then pass around those VMs as
assets you can also simply do
client-side compute right you could
actually have the computation running
JavaScript in the browser
or in Swift on iOS so that's sort of the
the building blocks in the second part
and in the third part for communications
this is really connecting networks and
you know history wise you know what's
interesting in with tcp/ip before tcp/ip
you had ARPANET you had NSFNET you had
CS net lots of universities and
otherwise we're creating all these
networks that they weren't talking to
each other and that was a problem right
and then Along Came Vint Cerf and Bob
Kahn and just kind of you know hanging
out doing their you know doing his PhD
and they did this thing to solve this
problem that they call tcp/ip they
convinced everyone to speak that
language of tcp/ip and they managed to
connect the networks so then they had a
network of networks which is now called
the internet right but the problem is
it's sending your own packets of data
but what if I have value that I want to
spend around right that you can double
spend packets it's ok but I don't want
someone double spending my my bitcoins
or my ether right or my air miles and so
what school there are now something like
tcp/ip for value so I can actually send
Bitcoin from one network to the next to
the next and this is via a protocol
called internal protocol ILP there's
another one that's emerging called
cosmos as well so they're kind of
competitive what's also cool you can
actually go beyond not just connecting
networks of value but you can connect
them of state so think of it like you've
got a smart contract running on
aetherium but imagine if it wants to hop
to another network that supports some
more contract this is actually possible
now or it's actually coming down the
pipe also via something called polka dot
as well as technology called eternity so
that it's a couple competitive
technologies think of it like a computer
a computer virus with its own Bitcoin
wallet that can hop across different
networks okay so this is all technology
that is emerging now this is actually
not part of the the broad discourse yet
in the world of blockchain but it will
write so don't think of blockchain as
one now and one giant and monolith that
does all the things it's actually a
whole bunch of different pieces of the
compute stack and this is actually
what's emerging of course if you think
of what for AI then once again we care
about storage and we care about compute
right to handle this massive data so for
file systems we've got things like IP FS
file coin and that's quite mature that's
why I bolded it
we've got databases like big gene d bi
PDB also quite mature 1.0 actually
it's coming on Monday and then we have
high performance compute and the most
mature stuff there is VMs and containers
and so on as well as simply client-side
compute and I will talk about some
architectures later so this is a kind of
where I've talked about the importance
of data I've talked about the stack that
we have in the world of AI I've talked
about this emerging compute stack for
decentralization but you might ask why
why does this affect me how does this
help me and this is what I'm going to
get to sort of hinting at these problems
I meant I mentioned before I started
giving a talk similar to this about nine
months ago and at the time there is only
a handful of things out there that we're
getting deployed at all now there's
actually probably dozens of applications
with that are connecting AI and
blockchain and so I'm going to now I
have the luxury of actually picking and
choosing the super interesting
applications that combine AI and
blockchain and that's what I'll talk
about now so to start with for this
problem of data hoarding right where
data is the new mode it's not about the
algorithm this is actually about the
data right why would Google or Facebook
or LinkedIn give up their data but
imagine if you can if there's value if
you have five or ten organizations in an
ecosystem they share their data what are
the benefits that can come oh so in the
project called genesis of things which
is with cognizant with energy with intel
and others and we're part of this too
there is the idea of the problem is
fraud with 3d printing so if I design
some CAD file with AutoCAD and I go to
have it manufactured in China or
somewhere else
someone might copy that CAD file and
then start printing on their own
printing on their own right this is
really an issue so imagine though that
there's the the ecosystem itself keeps
track of all the different designs that
are done by the different companies so
you know maybe 99% of the designs are
done by five or ten companies or 50
while those companies those five or 50
companies all put their designs into one
pool and it can be properly private and
so on - but whenever a design gets
manufactured then if it has a pasta is
possibly using one of those designs then
an email gets sent to the the possible
rights holder saying hey you know this
might be using what you
designed right so it's not blocking your
design it's just informing the right
solders that hey you know your thing is
getting your your design your CAD file
is getting printed right and then from
that you can decide for yourself hey was
this legit was this not legit and so on
but at least you have visibility into
what's going on so this is actually a
very very useful because otherwise we
could have flagrant stealing of IP and
it's expensive to design things air
prior aircraft turbines etc right so
this is one example here where if you
can actually pool the data
what's happening here using
decentralization technology and reverse
3d search basically then you actually
end up with a solution for the whole
ecosystem there's a similar example of
this in the world of diamonds we
actually worked on this more than a year
ago in the world of diamonds a fraud is
also a big issue it's about 40% fraud in
the world of diamonds what that means is
if someone is selling a diamond on eBay
they could claim something about that
diamond that's completely wrong
they might have actually gotten it by
all means it might be a Blood Diamond
one of these bad things but imagine if
you actually knew the whole province of
the diamond the whole story from the
time that it was dug out of the ground
right then you could actually claim that
it was you know a legitimate diamond and
if it was a cubic zirconium or something
synthetic that's okay too you just know
the story so when you go to buy
something off of ebay or whatever then
you just know where it comes from and it
turns out that the stuff coming out of
the ground is actually certified by just
about five Diamond shops that's it
certification houses so what's happening
now is these five houses are actually
pooling their data together and once you
have that then you can actually
cross-reference the diamond that shows
up in eBay with what is being pooled on
from these five certification houses and
so basically from that once you pool
then you can start to see is it going to
is it fraudulent or not but you have to
ask how do you check and one of the
checks we actually built a model that
predicts the price of a diamond based on
its characteristics and it's mostly the
four C's which is the carats the weight
the color and a couple others and with
that you can actually predict the price
and so if you see a diamond on eBay that
the price is radically different than
what you predict that's a yellow flag
that's saying hey you know maybe this
diamond is for
right and there are a whole bunch of
other things that you can check for too
so any diamond show up on eBay it might
have ten or twenty yellow flags and or
it might have zero and if it is zero
yellow flags and zero red flags then
you're probably okay
but it if it has one red flag or several
yellow flags then you might worry a lot
right so pooling data once again is very
helpful here keeping going
what about monetizing your algorithms
right so imagine you write some code you
design an algorithm you manifest it yeah
as code
well what about claiming that as IP it's
actually possible right it's an idea
that's manifested so just to show it as
an example where we started back in 2014
like Valentine's ster mentioned was with
our first project was called ascribe so
it's IP in the blockchain so what I did
was I as an example to show here I took
cart tree that I had done in the
mid-2000s for analog circuit design and
I simply ascribed it I I claimed the
copyright to it on the blockchain not
just this image but also the ideas below
behind and so then basically now I've
claimed the copyright I can then license
that to others right in this case I said
there's three possible licensees so
there's scarcity and if you want to buy
this from me you can you can come up
afterwards give me five bucks you know
I'll transfer one of the licenses to you
using blockchain under the hood and all
the proper legals of course - so under
the hood this chase just takes care of
it so that's what the scribe another
example so the problem of monetizing
algorithms right so numr I many of you
might know about it it's it's pretty
interesting it's a hedge fund but
instead of you know five smart folks in
a corner designing algorithms very
quietly and secretively
what numr I does is it's gathered
together a community of more than 10,000
data scientists they can any one of them
can submit an algorithm and that
algorithm then starts trading and if the
algorithm does well then the data
scientist as well and número gets their
cut right but there was a problem right
let's say that número makes ten thousand
dollars in a day if my algorithm does
the best then I get a higher cut but it
also means that it wouldn't tell my
buddies who are good at data science
about número because it's a zero-sum
game so I'm not going to tell anyone
not incentivized but what new Mirai did
was they said okay let's tokenize so
let's say basically all the data
scientists participating so far get a
token based on participation so far but
and this token you can buy and sell on
crypto exchanges just like Bitcoin and
aetherium but now if if numeron does
well on any given day then not only with
my algorithm for example then not only
do I win personally but everyone else
wins too in the ecosystem because the
value of número goes up then or there
their coin is called numeraire actually
so basically what's happened is they
have converted a zero-sum game to a
positive sum game via tokens and the
tokens align the interests of everyone
in the ecosystem in an economic fashion
this is really a key point so it's sort
of taking the idea of decentralization
like I mentioned as a benefit and the
idea of assets and swirling them
together towards on this this token the
alignment of incentives of the
participants and an ecosystem and that's
a very powerful idea and this is
actually this core idea is one of the
things that is driving all this ico
madness these days keeping going you
know what a moat if I've already secured
my work on the blockchain but it spreads
online right and spreads everywhere
wouldn't it be cool wouldn't be great to
have visibility into what's going on you
know I could try to lock it up you know
classic to your em style but that
doesn't really benefit anyone but what
if I simply just have visibility into
where my stuff went so I had the example
of 3d designs before for 3d parts but
you can of course also do this for
images on the web and this is actually
we did this in late 2015
called we're on the net so you can take
an image in this case it's Doge because
you know a lovely little dog and um the
godfather of the dogecoin you can put it
on to wear on the net and then it will
tell you what is the number of copies
versus time and it starts you know in
2014 and just started taking off
that's when dogecoin was released and
now there's actually more than 2500
copies of this and each different color
is a different website so there's one
website that really loves Doge it's got
more than a thousand copies right so
this is very useful because it gives
this feeling of control back to the
creators and you can do this not just
with your friendly neighborhood Doge but
you can do with your company logo if you
want to see how your popularity is
growing or you can do with your your
face if you're very vain and so
so so and so on keeping going going back
to the data problem right
I mentioned this problem of garbage in
garbage out week data history well
what's really amazing blockchain
technology you combine the immutability
with decentralization and this unlocks
the idea of audit trails for data and
learning right so basically every single
step of the modeling process and the
deployment process you could actually
times down so when you have your sensor
an input stream data coming in that can
actually be distort stored decentralized
it can be time-stamped into something
like ipfs the interplanetary files
sorry IP DB interplanetary database and
then from that you create your training
X Y data you can timestamp that store it
the same choice if you want even the
model building itself you can be storing
the convergence curves and all the
artifacts from that and now you have the
model then when you deploy the model
once again you've got your testing data
container or your field data the model
simulation and the testing data each one
of these steps can be actually time
stamped onto a blockchain database a
planetary database and even stored if
you want right so now you actually know
the whole history of what's going on if
you find that you've got some terrible
terrible model performance then you can
go backwards and see what's going on
it's basically like FX or conciliation
in the financial world but here it's
reconciliation for a I'm models and
training and this really matters for
example in the world of self-driving
cars if a car crashes and kill someone
would it be nice to know exactly where
things went wrong right and so this is
this is an example so keeping going
actually let's talk about cars a bit if
you go to buy a used car at some used
car lot there's at least in Canada
there's this idea of a sleazy used-car
salesman there you know the most
untrustworthy person in the world
they're gonna lie what lyin' lyin' lyin'
even worse than statistics they'll lie
in order to sell you the car and worth
more than it is because he gets his
percentage his commission or her and so
imagine though instead you actually knew
the whole history of the car and that
history isn't spread to the whole world
but they exposed that history to you
when you're looking at buying the car so
you might be able to see all the time
everywhere the car has driven every oil
change the time of purchase every owner
all of that right and it can actually be
shared securely to you
just in the moment of purchase or in the
consideration you can see what's going
on it can't be changed and in this way
when you go to buy the car you actually
have a much better understanding of
what's going on so this is something
that we're working on working with
energy and with Volkswagen in something
called car pass and this is a prototype
that we announced a couple of months ago
basically and you can see actually it's
got some pretty interesting graphs every
single entry there is another trip
that's recorded and then it kind of
shows the trip that went on and then you
can also see well there's a bunch of
interesting stats on top right so just
with d3 and stuff like that so that's
basically an example of car pass with
provenance of vehicle data and you can
do data mining on this of course too so
there's a bit of you know statistics
here but of course you can build fancier
models and fancier models so another
kind of interesting thing is when we do
storage of large data sets or compute
it's pretty expensive right
s3 they have their markup compared to if
your story on your own hard drives and
ec2 is even more expensive and you know
if you're using one of the services like
Google's service for TP use and so on
these all cost money what's interesting
there's markets now emerging for storage
of the raw data blobs data sets as well
as for compute so for the storage I've
mentioned them briefly before storage IO
file a coin and so on these are
basically driving the cost down of
storage so these things are often
one-tenth the cost of storing an s3 not
only that they're decentralized so so
that's actually quite powerful and
they're just more cheering now on same
thing with high performance compute
these ones aren't quite mature yet but
these are marketplaces basically buying
and selling compute so in the past you
know you might have donated your compute
time for like folding at home but you're
just donating it's like a charity here
you're actually letting your compute to
time be used but you're actually making
money from it right and not just for
mining bitcoins where you would have no
chance but for actually whatever people
want to do moving on with data you know
there's this big challenge of data being
expensive and really hard to price so
what's the ultimate way to unlock data a
data exchange or data marketplace to be
more precise and
what why I say that sometimes data is
fungible you can exchange you know one
mile driven of self-driving car data for
others in some cases but that said you
know one mile driven in a blizzard in
Canada is worth more than one mile
driven in sunny California and it's not
just because Canada is better right
so anyway well that of course is my
opinion but anyway so what we actually
did we worked with Toyota research and
others to build a prototype of a data
exchange for self-driving car data so
their challenge actually that they have
a Toyota and most self-driving cars it
comes down to the unreasonable
effectiveness of data you can build a
self-driving car algorithm with you know
ten thousand miles driven but you'll
have an error rate of say ten percent
right so do you want one in ten times
the car drives it to crash or kill
someone right it can't be one in a
hundred it needs to be one in a billion
or on that range right it needs to be at
least as safe as a human driving and
ideally 10x R or more better right the
problem is to get there Toyota and
others have calculated that they need
500 billion to one trillion miles driven
right that is a lot of resources that's
a lot of miles driven so so Toyota
Toyota said hey why don't we work with
other auto manufacturers doing
self-driving data and others like uber
etc and Pooler data together and not
just say you know let's let's kumbaya
and hug and everyone just share but I
should just charge each other a
reasonable price right and that's
basically what's going on here so it's
actually a data marketplace for the for
self-driving car data the prototype we
call the AV Dex autonomous vehicle data
exchange and you can see you know you
can enter data sets you can set a price
you can buy it and also we actually have
some privacy prefers preserving features
with this stuff called zero knowledge
proof which is basically sort of like
Monte Carlo sampling on information for
privacy so these are basically some some
interesting examples of what's happening
in the world of AI and watching together
how decentralization is actually helping
AI there's sort of another side twist as
well I'll be very quick here AI dows
it's a really interesting symbiosis of
how AI and blockchain work together a
dao
is a decentralized autonomous
organization it's basically code that
can run around
on the net but it actually can own its
own resources right it's got its own
Bitcoin wallet right so a quick
background you know in the world of AI
there's actually been people doing
creative AI for a long time my friend
Greg for example you know his day job
was NASA and now Facebook but his
evening job for fun for many years was
basically jewelry design so he set up a
shop called or beanie and it looks and
feels like Amazon but it shows all these
designs and every single one of these is
automatically generated with a variant
of genetic programming and if you click
on it you click on any one of these
necklaces then it will come up with
another 20 variants of that necklace so
it really is actually earth's largest
jewelry store under the hood you know
there's billions of designs and then
when you like it as I design you click
it and it basically 3d print set and get
sent to you so that's our beanie the
point is this is already you know 10 15
year old technology so in the world of
AI this creative AI it's been happening
a long time myself I did my PhD on
creative AI of analog circuit design and
about 10 years ago moving on though and
there's also you know beyond creative AI
there's AG ice and we probably all know
this but it's the idea of agents that
can sense and model the world and act on
that model of the world and repeat
repeat repeat and this could be like
agents running around in Minecraft or
something else but it can also be
something much more general the very
core of alphago for example actually had
a model of a GI as a control system and
that actually is a way that you can
frame a GIS in this sort of control
system standpoint and then you could
leverage the math and the theory that
goes back to norm to Weiner in the 50s
so going then let what if you mix all
this together this idea of daos
decentralized autonomous organizations
with AI with creative AI in sort of this
feedback loop fashion and the example I
give here is something that I call the
arch Dow so here's the recipe you've got
this this Dow running it's running some
script on decentralized substrate and it
generates some piece of art or some
jewelry design automatically you know
using genetic programming or in deep
learning whatever generates this new
image then it claims attribution on the
Chane claims IP whatever it sells it on
a marketplace could be on eBay or some
decentralized marketplace like open
Bazaar and then it tells us right so
maybe it spent $1 worth of compute power
to create this thing but it sells it for
10 right so it sells this thing
so this basically money coming into it
in exchange for the IP that it's created
right and then basically you repeat you
repeat repeat so now it's got ten
dollars instead of $1 it creates ten new
pieces of art sells each one of those
for $10 now let's go to $100 rinse
repeat rinse repeat ten dollars to one
hundred to a thousand keep going you've
got the world's first AI millionaire
right or even billionaire and as a quick
aside to you might ask yeah but does it
have any rights well actually there's
rules in Switzerland there's a town
called xub Switzerland where you can
actually have a corporation where no
flesh-and-blood humans need to be
attached what that means is you can
actually take a corporation you can
automate it very simply Dow style and
then you can basically give it some this
AI knowledge and it's basically given
this AI right because corporations have
rights right corporations are people too
so AI Dow is basically are people too so
this AI doubt that we've created it
actually does have the same rights as a
corporation because it literally is a
corporation right so this is kind of a
fun concept and there's a whole bunch of
things that fall out of this right and
I've written and talked a lot more about
this so given that this is PI data I
thought I'd just take a few minutes very
quickly and talk to about deployment
architectures how can you as Python
experts interested in AI and blockchain
to apply this yourselves right so
there's a very very simple architecture
to start with and this is simply only
have storage that's decentralized you
can have a decentralized database where
it's basically you're you're seeing
databases of service but you know
there's no Amazon or Atlas or [ __ ]
behind it's just this decentralized
website so that is basically like IP DB
you you can also have the decentralized
file system right and this would be like
ipfs etc but and in the front side you
just have JavaScript running in the
browser right or Swift running an iOS
etc so
deadly simple and by the way we've
actually worked this out in practice
many times the example I gave before
with the decentralized data exchange it
was actually using this architecture and
we already worked out things like
identity where you just pass in
basically your private key as a brain
wallet it's sort of like a simple way to
think about your private key and it does
all the identity stuff securely on the
client side and by the time it hits the
database and so on basically there's no
storage of any identity things so
there's a very nice sharing back and
forth so a very very simple architecture
you can get going
you know if you're a Java pure
JavaScript developer then this is this
is perfect right it just feels like
database-as-a-service s3 etc but of
course if you want to start pulling in
some heavy lifting from ml then what you
can do is create your own service ml as
a service or someone else's right from
Amazon or whatever and then you've got
this sort of mix of some decentralized
on the left including you know who owns
what and then some centralized ml as a
service all connected in a browser side
in the client side right so this is also
a very simple architecture over all
right you just got a few services all
speaking HTTP to the JavaScript side we
can keep getting a bit heavier so sort
of we can use the sort of mass compute
side where for storing large blobs of
data we can use Hadoop s3 but also maybe
ipfs for database we might have some
stuff in MongoDB or something as well as
in the interplanetary database for
business logic maybe just straight-up
ec2 and then leverage high performance
compute like before you know NVIDIA GPUs
etc so in this case everything basically
stays centralized except for the one
thing that really matters and that's who
owns what that is decentralized and
that's what goes into IP DB ok so this
is actually makes it easy to deploy
blockchains in AI because you can
actually maintain your whole system all
of your software and so on and all
you're doing is plugging in to IP DB via
the HTTP API and of course you can go
full-blown to this whole idea of
decentralized all the things so this is
in line with the stack that I talked
about before so and in this case by the
way to going back here
of course you'd have Django or flask or
something right some good Python back in
you can also though decentralize all the
things and in this case decentralized
filesystem decentralized database
decentralized the business logic and
high performance compute and in this
case it's basically the same things as
before the high performance compute you
would use something like VMs as assets
that's the more mature one or maybe true
bit which is coming down the pipe and
there's even actually platforms like
something's anguish in the for at the
higher level and this is things like Mon
acts or block ops so there's basically
this spectrum of things that you can do
from very very simple to more and more
full-blown decentralized right so with
those stacks and with what I've given
you as some applications right how might
you get going right and it's actually
much simpler than you might think
you don't need to go and take a
month-long course a two-month long
course from some purported blockchain
expert who will charge you an arm and a
leg you just need to sit down and start
coding and the interfaces have gotten
much simpler and I'll use an example
from from my work simply because well I
do it and I think it's nice and simple
so you can actually go to beta a bikini
be calm slash get started this will get
released it won't be beta starting a
Monday but right now it's this and
you'll see basically it's got JavaScript
so this is the single page web app as a
demo on the left it says let's write a
message into a planetary blockchain
database so you type in a message and
and then you click off you go right and
I'm in this case I typed I just did this
an hour ago and copied and pasted into
my screen I typed L apply data and then
what it did was it took that message and
it automatically using the JavaScript
driver in this case it fleshed out Jason
where Hal applied data was a key message
and it sent that off to the
interplanetary database so this is
basically the the public database of
bikini B and this is the jason that it's
stored in there and you can see that
it's got a message called he'll apply
data and also it's sorted as an asset
and it says nicely done you've just
created an asset sent in a signal and
receive the response and if you want you
can click on it and see basically the
Explorer to to browse what else is on IP
dB
and so this is just a demo in JavaScript
but if you want then on the bottom left
here it's hard to see but it shows you
examples using curl Python and nodejs
and I will zoom in on what this looks
like for Python so in this case it was
just using the node.js stuff but if you
want to do something in Python it can be
actually quite simple so maybe you guys
can see this but maybe I'll just read
out the key things so you for Python
there's a library up in pi pi for the
driver so and it's big called Victini be
underscore driver you import that as
well as one of the key pair parts from
the crypto library and then there's just
a few key steps first of all you you
create an instance a driver-side
instance of the database so this is just
you know the pointer to the database of
course you point to a URL in this case
it's IP DB then you generate a key pair
which is basically the public and
private key it's sort of your identity
with your password right and then you
create a transaction where you're just
specifying the message in this case
hello pi data you're signing the message
and this is really a key thing right so
signing message is proving later on then
people can see that it truly was you
that created that message so you're
signing it with your private key right
and then you're pushing in to the
network so it's basically creating this
JSON blob signing it and then sending it
to the network very straightforward and
that's very similar to what you're doing
in a normal database where you create
some JSON and you push it to the
database and the one extra step is just
simply signing it which is really key
right so it's very straightforward I
encourage you guys to try it for
yourself so basically in literally like
five minutes you could actually be
creating data putting it onto a
blockchain blockchain database and it
should be that simple it is that simple
if you think of it as a database you
don't need to go and become some
blocking expert just like to drive a car
you don't need to know the mechanics of
internal-combustion and if someone tells
you otherwise they probably don't know
what they're talking about and there's a
lot of those people in the blockchain
world by the way so because there's a
lot of money right so and of course then
to bring in the AI it's only one import
away right import SK learn or your other
favorite and the library the stuff maybe
you've rolled yourself and then you
start building models and you can
or those in various ways on the database
etc in some of the use cases I've talked
about right so very straightforward it's
simple it should be simple don't let
anyone tell you otherwise so to kind of
wrap up my talk here block chains it
turns out can really help AI and the
core of it is it's all about the data
it's about getting the data via pooling
or via data exchanges but also getting
good data with provenance solving the
problem of garbage in garbage out and
then there's this you know pesky AI Dao
thing you know AI that can get rich code
that owns itself and there's a huge ways
to extrapolate beyond just a simple art
deal that I talked about and it's
actually much easier to get started with
AI and blockchain than any of you might
have realized right it's it's just a
couple imports away and so with that I
will conclude and leave the floor to
questions
[Applause]
so do we have any questions from the
audience also we're running about 15
minutes late so yeah so the entire
conference is running about 15 minutes
say you finished early Trent and so you
have plenty of time to answer questions
so there should be some people with
microphones please feel free to ask
thanks for the presentation spectacular
one question about this kind of the mic
isn't working okay but I can hear you
okay now Bravo for the presentation I
had one question about use of this kind
of technology and you know an enterprise
perspective not just for fun
one of the things that we have to deal
with in Europe is right to be forgotten
gdpr etc how does this kind of play with
this type of technology that is a
fantastic question and you know right to
be forgotten directly contradicts the
idea of immutability right the the
answer is actually encryption of
personal data the laws are actually
fuzzy on this if I actually have my
personal ADA that you know maybe my
birth date or something else being
stored encrypted in some public network
right now the law doesn't actually have
much to say if it's encrypted is it an
issue yes or no right so what's
happening is we are actually working
with the regulators here in Berlin for
Germany as well as for the EU giving
very specific guidance on how to update
the laws to account for the new
technology right so and in fact just
last week there was a big meeting of
about a dozen different blocking
organizations with the German government
on specific issues like this so that's
one of the issues there's also takedowns
right if someone puts up some you know
Disney frozen or something up one too
III PDB or ipfs you can't take it down
so what do you do and that there's
there's near-term answers to for this
and the near-term answers are D indexing
just like you know I can put something
up on the web and no one can take my
server down especially if I'm not in
Germany or something but at least Google
candy and Nexus search so the main
interface is to this thing can actually
be at least be made hard for the
mainstream right and the third related
thing in terms of regulations that's
really important is
these token lunches that are happening
right people call them I cos is a token
an asset or is it a security if it's
interpreted as a security then you have
massive security regulations especially
in the USA if it's an asset it's much
simpler but the law has been unclear so
far except for Switzerland and Singapore
where it's become very clear so that's
why most of the token lunches are out of
there so but going back to your original
question right to be forgotten it's a
big issue fortunately there are clean
solutions but it does involve working at
the regulator's and kind of related to
that too just as an addition this isn't
your grandma's blockchain anymore right
as in like Bitcoin it was all about sort
of like let's tear down the existing
institutions and break it all and let's
let's kill the banks and it's anarchy
and free-for-all full libertarian that's
a cool inspiring idea but my view is you
actually have to build bridges to exist
in society you have to work with the
laws and with the mainstream and see
what you can do with this new technology
and make the world a better place from
within right sure you can have
revolutionary ideas but it's it's about
building a bridge so in the case of the
right to be forgotten then it's actually
about working with the regulators and
it's kind of amazing they're
surprisingly receptive maybe I shouldn't
have been surprised this really matters
and they're actually reconciling with
the law
all right - any more questions yes
any more questions there was a question
just about and the right to be forgotten
another thing is when you actually lose
key right private private key it's it's
gone forever right yep yeah there's
actually different answers to that it
gets pretty complicated but it's
interesting when we first built ascribe
which was the IP in the blockchain we we
made it super simple right like you can
go to a scrub that I sign up you know
enter your uh your email choose a
password and then people would use it
you know claiming stuff and then they
would email us they said they'd say hey
I forgot my password and we'd say you're
screwed
like and actually you you I mean that's
how it works like with Bitcoin you lose
your coins and so on right so then we
started asking well how do we solve this
and one of the answers is multi-sig so
basically imagine there's multi-sig
means let's say two of three passwords
or private keys to unlock any given
thing so it could be you have one
private key and then the company like a
scribe has one private key or big chain
DB and then there's one private key held
by some third party trusted third party
okay and then if you lose your passport
password you contact that trusted third
party and then you also contact us and
we all agree and we unlock that key
that's one way there's also social
unlocking this is something that you
port is moving towards so you kind of
your social network around you
collectively helps you unlock kind of
you proving that you're you in the case
of ascribed what we did it was simpler
because it was just about provenance of
ownership and so on we had it saying if
you get a Kiwi you can get a password
reset a key reset and we just would
timestamp into the blockchain that you
got a key reset now of course this is
where you're just doing time stamping
it's not as good for transfers of value
but when it's time stamping it's okay so
of course this is slightly less
trustworthy because
if it's showing that you're you got a
key reset like a new key pair then what
if someone else stole so every time you
do that it compromises the trust a bit
more a bit more there are also hardware
wallets that people often carry so just
like you have a contract that says you
own a particular house you can have a
USB stick that has all your private keys
and this is actually becoming a pretty
big thing to insure and also you know I
would like to ask about the integration
of standard traditional Ledger's with
you know crypto Ledger's because really
you just mentioned inter ledger protocol
right but basically if you have a memory
of someone giving something to someone
else in human brain and or in some other
database for example email email
messages and so on this this information
is not accounted for actually you can't
only the blockchains matter is there
some kind of layer that would integrate
you know the blockchain world with with
the traditional world yeah so this is
once again a little building bridges
right so yes often people like to claim
you know block chains are a single
shared source of truth that's absolutely
wrong they're not truth machines they
are claim machines so when people make
claims that gets etched in stone
basically but it's what are the claims
that you make and other people can make
claims in your claims and so on so this
is part of the the key towards building
to the traditional world then you can
say okay well what are the ways that
these things make sense to work together
and this is all about the stack that I
was showing right so you can actually
have your traditional stack in the cloud
or whatever and add in another database
of blocks unity based also with big
Genie be itself when we went to build
this blockchain database we said what
are some great pieces of technology that
we can leverage so we actually wrap
MongoDB like we didn't have to do all
this amazing like a hot it's it's really
heavy lift to do sharding well it's a
really heavy lift to do low latency
query as well so we didn't bother
ourselves we took advantage of the great
work that the MongoDB guys did and we
also wrap rethink yeah one other
question if can I I'm afraid we're kind
of running a bit late now it's very
early
Chantal and I'd suggest you hook up with
Trent
immediately after the talk okay thanks
great let's thank the speaker once again
[Applause]